the only way DeSantis is going to become
the Republican nominee is if Trump
chooses not to run
and endorses him or dies
like I just don't see a world in which
Trump says I want it
let's say he says I want it and DeSantis
beats him fair and square in the primary
you really think the hardcore Maga is
going to abandon Trump for DeSantis
they're not
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the host of the Megyn Kelly show Megan
Kelly Megan I just said your name three
times that's four if I say Megan one
more time how are you I'm great how are
you good I realize that's quite an intro
if I say this is the host of the Megyn
Kelly show Megan Kelly and then I want
to say your name to bring you in yeah
it's a lot of Megan's a lot of Megan's
okay
but I got you how you doing sister
what's going on I'm doing great all is
well I'm I'm excited this has been a
great news cycle it always makes me
happy and uh my kids are in a good place
now so that makes me happy too all as
well
let's do the kids stuff first you fled
New York City you're in the suburbs over
there but you still are in the tri-state
area let's say uh are you protected
enough from the insanity just by leaving
Manhattan I'm yes I am and I'm so
excited I'm so thrilled we did it you
know we've talked about the awfulness of
the New York City private schools before
and how hardcore left they went I mean
hard core asking my boys and they're all
boys school regularly if they were sure
they were still boys that school no
longer refers to boys as boys they call
them your student go collect your
student they don't say son
um this was one of the more traditional
schools in the city that's why we chose
it if we wanted far left we would have
gone to Dalton we chose one that was
more traditional but it went hardcore at
the thing about you know race
essentialism and in every classroom
where white children learn there's a
future killer cop I mean they went far
left so we pieced out of there pretty
quickly and we found this school in
Connecticut when we did our homework of
course
still boys and girls because I have two
boys and a girl and my boys school in
particular has been outstanding my
little guy says the pledge every day we
went to the annual dinner where they you
know say hello to all the parents just
the other day last week and the head of
school stood out there and said we are
unabashedly pro-american here and we do
not believe in equity of outcome we
believe in equality of opportunity and
we don't believe in teaching these boys
what to think we want to teach them how
to think like Dave you or I could have
written this as the ideal ethos for our
school and so I was I mean a single tier
I was running up
thank God uh our goal girls school has
been better than where she was I
wouldn't say it's quite as great as the
boys but we're working on it
do you feel undue pressure when you send
your kids to a school I mean you're
Megan Kelly every administrator teacher
and all the other parents they're going
to know who you are they're going to
know that if they over step on something
or if they have an odd policy there's a
good chance you're going to talk about
it that's got to be a kind of delicate
balance because you also want to keep
your kids private and all that well I
don't talk about what schools we're at
or even what city we're in because I
really have had some very dark security
issues in my past as an anchor so just
as a security measure I don't do that
and so I wouldn't be embarrassing it
would take a massive fall down even even
when I left the New York City Schools I
I haven't named them I don't talk about
them by name I don't I'm not my goal is
not to embarrass anybody
um but if they cross the line far enough
I would have to it's definitely you know
an arrow in my quiver and hopefully they
won't necessitate it you know I I will
say like if something happened I've
become a squeaky wheel you know there
there was a memo that went out by one
teacher citing Kendy and anti-racist
this and I mean immediately I was on the
horn like what's this this and this
school was already on it they had
already taken care of it they were two
steps ahead of me so I knew I was in the
right place but
um I can't really worry about that and I
will say if I speak out publicly because
I for example my daughter's school they
were looking for a new head of school
and that we went to all the meetings and
I listened to every single candidate and
what she was saying on you know their
vision and I asked all the tough
questions about diversity Equity
inclusion the lovely name that doesn't
match up in practice
and I had so many parents come to me
after the fact saying thank you thank
you thank you thank you you know it's
like you know how it is when you're out
there like you're out there with your
opinions and so am I people are grateful
because they're still stuck on the other
side they don't feel like they can
especially touch those third rails and
so they feel really validated when they
hear somebody who's who can do so I I
can only imagine at like a school board
meeting how they're all staring at you
like Megan will do it we can just we
could just kind of sit back here she'll
she'll take care of it do you think your
politics have shifted at all in the last
couple years like I think you and I as
much as I can think of anyone in a
public sphere I think we're like pretty
darn close on things and whatever the
differences are it just doesn't matter
in terms of Being Human and friends
um but you know as things have spun out
of control over the last couple years do
you think you've shifted on certain
things
well I almost feel like I'm kind of the
same but the ground shifted beneath me
you know I didn't like radically change
my own positions but they've started to
mean different things I used to think I
was more liberal socially but I can't
say that now because what that means now
is you're Pro this radical trans agenda
and your pro-race essentialism I'm not
pro any of that it used to mean like I
don't know just an entirely different
field of things and I used to be more
Pro National Security and sort of the
National Security apparatus you know I'm
gen xer experience 911 on a personal
level
um
things have changed there too I
definitely think the farther we get from
911 the less we need a lot of those
tools and the more I see them being
abused my feelings about uh federal law
enforcement agencies like the FBI have
changed as we've learned more
information so I I feel like
the world has shifted and my opinions of
it have changed accordingly but I remain
non-ideological you know I'm at heart
I'm a soulless lawyer who wants to be
persuaded with facts if you come to me
with better facts instead of saying ah I
I was wrong I'll say hallelujah I've
learned something new I'm smarter today
than I was yesterday so I'm not
ideological I'm certainly not a
knee-jerk Republican or Democrat I'm
still a registered independent and
remain open-minded
does do you think that can work the the
independent thing like in sort of real
politic I know it can work for you
privately and personally but like that
in terms of just this craziness that
we're in it's either like we're gonna
usher in more of this woke stuff or
maybe we can stop it but the middle
thing is just again it's just getting
harder to hold in a way middle is not
the right word independent is different
Independence just I think
non-ideological and open to calling BS
on both sides
um but I'll give you an example I went
to uh one of these like events where you
show up and you have deep conversations
and people buy a ticket to listen and
one of the guys who was there spoke near
when I did was Andrew yang and I like
Andrew Yang a lot I I don't agree with
him on most of his positions but he's
the kind of democrat I could get behind
Tulsi gabbard she's the kind of democrat
I could get behind
in no world do I ever see myself backing
somebody like Matt gates for president I
I you know I could never back somebody
like AOC Margaret Taylor green is not my
cup of tea you know so
I don't know you know if it were
Marjorie Taylor green versus Andrew Yang
I'd probably go with Andrew Yang you
know so that's what I mean like yeah it
could work for me I don't know if it's
going to work for the country but for my
own personal politics I'd be fine with
that when you're doing your show every
day are there moments of uh of
frustration or is it just pure like
you're just getting the information in
and you kind of comment on it and talk
to people or does it wear on you ever
because I I'm like sort of for the most
part I'm pretty much enjoying the show
and all that stuff but every now and
again like I was on as we're taping this
now I was on your show earlier today and
it's like this Kamala thing with the
communities of color and the equity
stuff it it really was getting to me it
really was like maybe that's a little
bit of the the new father thing like I'm
feeling this like need for the Next
Generation suddenly in a new way or
something but like these are just
horrible ideas and bad people
yes and these culture wars in particular
really upset me and the covid overreach
really upset me the longer it went down
the thing that made me the maddest I've
been in probably the past two years was
the the shaming of parents who wanted
the masks off their kids like you
haven't done your part you don't care
you know about society and the old
people and it's like we've done our part
our children have done our part this has
been an absolutely senseless exercise
what you're doing to these kids and
finally parents had to stand up and
basically raise the middle finger and
say it's on whether we're Democrats or
Republicans it's on we're showing up at
your school board meetings we're we're
going to rhetorically torture you until
you listen to us and you can call us
terrorists you can send the FBI in we
don't give a fig we're not going
anywhere I felt it so many parents felt
it and we won that battle that that's
that's why Glenn Younkin won in Virginia
and and it's why the Democrats almost
immediately abandoned those positions
they recognized they were all going to
suffer the same fate as Junkin or the
governor Phil Murphy of New Jersey who
only won by two or three points was
expected to win by 30. they got it and
there's a reason the reason those kids
don't have masks on there in the schools
right now and that it's because the
parents that stuff fires me up when when
the weak or the vulnerable or the
smallest Among Us can't fight for
themselves and the kid thing was really
annoying he had people like Randy
Weingarten like they're resilient they
don't complain they're little they don't
know how to give voice to this stuff
like they're not loud mouths like you or
me we're here for them Randy Weingarten
is the enemy I'm sorry but she is the
enemy of children and she has to be
identified and treated as such and
frankly Dr fauci is in exactly the same
camp so I'm so glad you just said that
because that's where I was gonna what do
we do about these people I am not one
for jailing our political opponents and
I don't want to throw them in gulags and
all the things that they probably want
to do to us but when you look at
somebody like Randy Weingarten who's now
taking the reverse of all the positions
or claiming that she took is taking the
reverse of all the positions she had for
two years and fauci who you know uh not
wearing masks at a baseball game while
telling us to wear masks all the stuff
everyone knows all this stuff what do we
do with these people like publicly what
what should happen over and over and
over and I really think this is one
hopeful thing about the Republicans
taking the house which we believe they
will uh I mean it would take a massive
disaster between now and the election
day for the Republicans to lose the
house but
um they're going to investigate fauci
and I know he went out there and said
like I'll consider it if they play nice
you know I didn't I didn't appreciate
the way I was treated before and I would
expect to be tree you'll show up and
you'll sit down and you'll answer the
questions or you you will be found in
contempt of congress that's how this
works you don't get to say maybe I'll
come right that's what a subpoena is for
so we could get some real answers if the
GOP takes over the house and invest the
covet Origins and more maybe not more
importantly but equally importantly the
cover-up by our Public Health officials
what the hell went wrong at the CDC and
the NIH and how did they become such
huge Behemoth god-like institutions in
the eyes of the media and the Liberals
to where their quote science TM could
not be questioned because it's still
happening Dave I mean I I'm preparing
for a big interview that's going to hit
soon and I'm neck deep in this right now
the vaccines and the information about
the damage that the vaccines are doing
versus their efficacy is dark it's it's
not turning out the way even vaccine
proponents like yours truly wanted it to
why is it being buried why can't we talk
about it even journals like science and
nature and
um New England Journal of Medicine are
starting to release the studies showing
that there's a real risk in taking the
vaccine and then you get coveted after
you've taken the vaccine these are dark
times they can take you to Dark Places
and there's not an acknowledgment by
people like fauci he still wants vaccine
mandates they refuse to acknowledge that
the vaccine doesn't stop the spread and
yet we're still imposing the mandates as
though they do and then endangering
people who get the vaccine who don't
need it who then will probably get
covered anyway because it doesn't
protect you from getting the
transmission so you're really messing
with your immune system in dangerous
ways they won't acknowledge it the only
answer is public accountability an
outcry wasn't it also amazing how it's
like we had this Federal mask mandate on
the planes and then one judge in Tampa
is like no no no more everyone takes the
masks off the next day and there's no
spike in kovid there's no sudden
Outbreak on a plane that's you know
taking it over to Europe or vice versa
and but we don't really like stop and
acknowledge that like boy they just the
week before fauci was like yeah we
should extend it on the planes yeah I
know God bless that judge and some
people even on the right some lawyers I
respect ripped her opinion and I was
like you know what it's a great opinion
I totally agree with it
um and it stood right now it stands and
we've been fine we've been fine I don't
think the masks are going to come back I
really don't except for in like really
crazy leftist cities maybe New York City
you know maybe La
um I don't think they're coming back
because people have seen with their
children how damaging that is you know
they I still see people in the New York
area riding around with a mask in the
car by themselves but I think for the
most part we're done doing it on a
mandatory basis for children the vaccine
mandate though it's still in a lot of
places I think you said before that you
were a vaccine proponent does that mean
that you're not a vaccine proponent now
yes it does I was never a pro-mandate
but in the beginning I thought the
vaccine was a miracle you know I was
proud of American industry for coming up
with this thing so soon and the first
version of the vaccine seemed seemed
like the best one because there was I
believe still some measure of protection
protection against the spread uh of
covid and so that particular vaccine
worked fairly well against that original
version of covid and it's just gone
steadily downhill since then and so now
I've got some serious questions about
efficacy about dangers yes side effects
from the vaccine but also what are we
doing to our immune systems and other
other body bodily systems when we take
the vaccine that won't prevent us from
giving getting coveted and then we get
coveted so now you've had at least a
double shock to your immune system there
are questions about what it actually
does if anything to DNA there have been
denials and so on but more and more
information is starting to come out now
as you would expect we're two years into
having the vaccines you can't trust
the American public health services they
they have only one Mission which is to
push more vaccines on us you have to
start getting your information from the
UK from Sweden some from Finland uh from
Israel like there are countries who are
taking honest looks at this sadly we're
not one of them
and by the way every country you just
mentioned I mean they're making mistakes
too right like even you can get your
information from pretty much everywhere
and even then it's like it's hard to
tell what's true but I don't trust the
people who never revise their opinions
after new data comes right right you
know and I mean seriously like there's
now like in in the UK you're not
supposed to they're not recommending the
vaccine they don't they won't give it
unless there's special circumstances to
kids under 12. here at our school
there's a mandate in place now it
doesn't kick in until you're 16 but
there are still school systems in the
country where you have to get it under
age 12 or you're expelled that's what's
happening in Washington DC they just had
to hold off on it because it was going
to lead to half of their population and
that's a black school population that
wasn't going to be able to go to school
so they cared about that right but
they're mandating it now for young
people when we really have no idea
whether it's actually going to lead to
increasing cardiac events for young
children myocarditis and Beyond I
featured friends of mine Dave on my show
friends of mine who I got to know at the
beach their 17 year old son died
suddenly of a heart attack of a heart
incident caused by myocarditis he wasn't
sick he had coveted and he had the
vaccine and the family doesn't know they
don't know what led to his death but he
was perfectly able-bodied five months
after he got the vaccine and some about
a year after he had coveted he died of
myocarditis there's just been too many
incidents like that and if you look at
the rise in cardiac events amongst young
people now
um it's disturbingly high and it seems
to follow you if you look at the graphs
in these magazines I've seen something
like far left or far right magazines
um they follow spikes in the vaccination
rate they don't follow spikes in covid
like the outbreak of Omicron it's not
like all the cardiac deaths were
happening then amongst the young people
they have been following the increases
in vaccination rates country to Country
so
look all of that disturbs me and gives
me pause and as a journalist says I want
to know more I want to know more and I
know where not to look I will not look
at Rachelle wolensky or Anthony fauci or
anybody at the NIH or the who I mean
fauci just gave another Grant to Peter
dazick's group ecohealth Alliance
another 600 plus thousand it's going to
go up to 3.3 million to do more bat
coronavirus research in China these are
the people that we're looking to for
answers no so I'm still looking for the
perfect advisor but I know that they're
overseas
and uh as I'm sure you saw uh fauci's
net worth increased by five million
dollars in the last two years that's
bizarre
and why is it that a public health
official can get a million dollar award
in a role like his for speaking truth to
power that's that's disturbing right
like yeah the highest salary in the
federal government and the highest
retirement salary well so he can
basically be bought all you have to do
is come up or maybe Pfizer is going to
give him the next million dollar award
for speaking truth to power uh but the
coziness between big Pharma the media
and the the larger government
has not worked to our advantage and the
media you know
I interviewed RFK Jr and he was making a
point about how the big Pharma owns the
media he's not wrong if you look at who
advertises all over broadcast media and
cable it is it's drug companies it's
advisor did you ever see that
compilation have you ever seen that
compilation from the morning show oh I
got I'll text it to you after this
there's an incredible it's like a
three-minute compilation of all of the
news shows ABC NBC CBS CNN everybody all
going in and out of commercial brought
to you by Pfizer as they're reporting on
Pfizer you can't and they're they're so
rich there it's an unlimited spend you
know it these companies are businesses
that was one thing I realized in my 17
years at Fox News
it was a business it was a business
first it's not a public service none of
them is I mean Fox is not unique in that
way they want to put on programs that
rate they're not looking to do in-depth
reports on homelessness if they don't
think it's going to rate I remember the
terrible earthquake down in Haiti and uh
our biggest conclusion looking at the
fall in numbers was Haiti no Rady like
that's I remember we talked about it
because it was just the dregs in terms
of numbers and very quickly we and CNN
and everybody else moved off of Haiti
why because we didn't care about people
in Haiti no it's just so far away that
the American consumers weren't
interested in that story and so if we
were truly just a public service we
would have stayed on it but news is not
and so we all moved on pretty quickly do
you feel like what level of Freedom do
you feel now doing your independent
thing that you didn't feel either at Fox
or at NBC
I mean complete Freedom complete now I
can say whatever I want about whatever I
want or whomever I want and and that's
lovely because while Fox censored me far
less than anybody else ever did I mean
NBC was far worse than Fox when it came
to this is how you have to say it this
is the way we want it you know
approached yeah um can you give me an
example of that like that type of thing
that you were getting well I mean
everything everything out of your mouth
at NBC is controlled you on my morning
show you'd have scripts you know that
they put in the prompter and everything
would be run by uh standard and
practices so the lawyers come through
every word with a fine-tooth comb would
want to change especially we did a lot
of these metoo stories that were
breaking at the time where they wouldn't
want to change it to this or change it
to that and I as a lawyer lawyer would
be like that's not necessary that's
that's overreach we're airing too far on
this side or that and um I was not in
control they were in control then I
would want to ask my own questions
because that's all I had ever done at
Fox nobody writes your questions at Fox
um and they would get upset they wanted
the producers to write my questions and
that's where I said I'm not doing that
that I draw the line that's literally
what you're paying me for to use my
brain and come up with questions I had
one case we were discussing a Supreme
Court case and a producer had given me a
packet she was not a lawyer they had
just hired her from Al Jazeera and she
wanted me to answer to ask her questions
this like toddler from this other one
I'm like okay I practiced a lot for 10
years I covered the high court for three
years and I've been a journalist for 17.
you could take a seat I will ask my own
questions so that that was a frustration
at NBC and by the way I did
um at Fox it was more understood you
know and and I was on board with the fox
mission that they were an antidote to
the left-wing bias in media if you're
going to work at Fox News your goal is
not to pick up the New York Times and
put it on TV your goal is to try to take
another look at the stories that are out
there and see what the media is missing
see if there is another side to be told
and so sometimes there isn't but usually
there is so yeah that's but that's not
my mission in my current job my current
job is just to give my honest take on
the day's news no matter where it lands
and however the agenda is I don't care
like the viewers will come or they won't
but it's it's honest and it's definitely
not ideological
do you wish that at some level
mainstream media was better or at this
point do you think the ship has just
sailed and it's like people will find
you now they'll find me and For Better
or Worse we're all just going to go in
our directions and so be it
um I think it's over for them it's over
um you know they're they're gone but not
forgotten and I think they're just on
their last legs right now sort of
wobbling around about to fall and be and
it's I just think it's done for them
um I think it's too late to resurrect
them so today we talked about Chris
Cuomo and uh his his new show and he
goes out there and he says on news
Nation I'm going to be sort of the
moderate voice okay I'm gonna be the
voice of reason who's going to give it
to you in a non-party give me a break
CNN right now is trying to do the same
thing after all these years of telling
everyone who's in the center or right of
not just we're not with you we hate you
now that they see that that's a failing
business model they want to turn
everything around and say you can trust
us we're in the middle we're the voice
of reason [ __ ] nobody believes that
so that works to your advantage and to
my advantage because I think in both of
our cases we have a history of not being
blinded by ideology we've been open to
facts and new information and honest
about that Journey too with our with our
viewers so that's our advantage it's not
theirs and I don't think the media is
going to come back from what they did to
themselves during Trump as I always say
on the show it's like For Better or
Worse whatever I'm saying on the show is
coming out of my mind so it's like it
all falls on me but one of the things
I'm always amazed about is on the
network side that these guys that screw
up or get caught in massive lies or
their ratings are horrible they rarely
get fired they just get shifted so Brian
Williams NBC Nightly News I don't even
remember what it was he got fired for he
lied about all the lies he told all the
lies about him remember he was like
basically with SEAL Team Six
so then he gets fired from that gig and
they give him a show on MSNBC Don Lemon
no one's watching says crazy things
every night they take him off prime time
they put him in the morning like it's
almost like they're showing us how
insane the whole thing is yeah well they
they don't care because those people are
on the right side ideologically which is
the left right like they would have
gotten rid of them a long time ago if
they hadn't been saying the things that
the network Executives wanted them to
say I mean the Don Lemon case really
brings it home because as soon as they
had a shift in management he literally
went out on the air and reminded
everyone that he's black and he's gay
li like that's where we are in our
society Justin I mean I should have
tried this at NBC I should have been
like just in case you're thinking about
getting rid of me I have a vagina
laughs
Megan if I'm not mistaken a former
president once talked about your vagina
so you know
yeah as you might know I've got one and
uh it's so pathetic though right and so
why did he do that because it works it
they didn't keep Don Lemon at CNN
because they thought we'll build a show
around him in the morning that was his
excuse they're gonna build something
around me I'm like more about you than
your own show in the prime time with
your name and only your name on it
because guess what Don this is a
demotion in any event they did it
because he's in the right identity boxes
and he's he's a thinker of the kind they
like right he's not uh um he's not a
black gay conservative that would be a
bridge too far they're not going to take
Christian Walker and put him in the Don
Lemon slot anyway so he's got all that
going for him and the same thing with
you know somebody like a Chris Cuomo who
stayed a lot longer than he should have
right because he's somebody who thinks
the way they do and he's tied to the
larger Cuomo Empire it's funny because I
heard Chris Chris Cuomo say the thing
about I'm going to be the voice or
reason or something and it's like well
well what were you doing what do you
think you did for the last five years I
mean yeah what are you admitting or or
if you're going to admit it then admit
it do the full mayor culpa and then
maybe we can yeah he he may occult blood
over protecting his brother not over
being a partisan hack turning himself
into it that's what I mean here's what's
annoying like when I was at Fox News I
would make headlines a lot inadvertently
you know the media would just pick it up
because I'd I'd have very contentious
moments with very well-known Republicans
right from Newt Gingrich to Dick Cheney
to Donald Trump and Beyond but I would
also make a lot of headlines for the
fights I had with Democrats from Donna
Brazil to Anthony Weiner and Beyond I
have a history I can actually point to
to tell the audience I will challenge
any politician you've put in front of me
because I'm not blinded by my own
political opinions what can Chris Cuomo
point to in his past that would back up
his I'm the voice of reason to trust me
to not get sucked into the harsh
partisanship of TV news [ __ ] it was
a lie because he needs to turn over a
new leaf and so he needs to hope and
pray that people don't believe
their Lying Eyes that they've looked
through for the past 12 years or however
long he was there doing that so Speaking
of Chris Cuomo you you are a former New
Yorker they got rid of his brother in
the midst of this uh coveted craziness
and I don't know if you know this but it
so it happened during August last August
when they got rid of him so I didn't
know about it for a couple weeks because
I'm off the grid and then Corolla is
bringing me back on the grid and he says
you know they got rid of Andrew Cuomo
before he even said who she he was being
replaced with I said I guarantee you
whoever it is it's going to be worse and
it's fairly obvious that Kathy hotel is
far even despite the fact that he killed
all these people and our friend janistan
what happened to her her you know
in-laws and all of this stuff yeah but
she's she's the worst of the worst I
mean are do you think that New York or
California these places do you think
they can ever turn around or are they
just going to be perpetually on that
slide now
hmm
I don't know because both New York and
California have had Republican Governors
if they have large pockets of red you
know their their Statewide elections
have been dominated by democrats for
years now but you know Upstate New York
and Long Island and parts of New York
are in Western New York still very red
and obviously that's true in California
too uh it just doesn't have to be true
of their major cities like New York City
and LA certainly San Fran
um so I don't want to say it's never
possible to have reason restored and it
wouldn't have to be a republican you
know I mean it could be an Andrew Yang
type or a Tulsi gabbard type Democrat
somebody who just had it and was ready
to call BS I still think is a lifelong
New Yorker you know not New York City or
but New York stator
um that could happen in my state I have
faith in the reason of most people
living in New York you know I think that
what's happened in New York and you know
you'd know better than I in California
is the loudest voices have dominated the
discussion and shamed the vast majority
of their party into going along and now
that's become policy and now we're
seeing the real life results of that
policy for example defund the police and
slowly but surely those policies are
falling apart
now covid is its own unique brand of
insanity our governor in New York is
wearing a vaxxed necklace it's a
republican I can't help people like that
they're gone they're too far gone we
just need a new a new ruler a new
governor to replace her so I I don't
want to say never but probably no time
soon I mean when I heard her say that
line a couple weeks ago about how
Republicans don't share our New York
values and go down to Florida it's like
I don't know that I've ever heard a
republican a sitting you know in office
Republican say anything that disgusting
about half the people that live in their
city and yet it's becoming sort of
commonplace with the way they they speak
about half the country yeah well I mean
it's like Governor Cuomo said that too
uh 10 years ago when he was still in the
office and at least Governor Cuomo has a
name that's been in New York we all
loved Mario Cuomo backwards at least
he's got some like street cred when it
comes to being a New Yorker Kathy hokel
who who are you you weren't even elected
we didn't want you with your weird
necklace and your two blushy cheeks I
don't like take a seat again I I want
her to just be quiet
and she's become this hardcore activist
she is awful she's the worst politician
she can't give a speech she's there's
nothing relatable about her
so I'm even more offended by her
comments and then he got Charlie Chris
down there like don't vote for me if you
you voted for this and I was like
weren't you a Republican like two
minutes ago like you're even more
soulless and spineless than Cuomo
um so yeah I don't think that they speak
for the vast majority of their party I
think smart politicians want votes from
wherever they come uh but it just kind
of shows you how tribal we've gotten
yeah so you know I'm down here obviously
in Florida now and it's been a little
hard for me to try to figure out what's
going on with the mainstream media when
it comes to this hurricane but it's
pretty obvious because I don't have
cable anymore so I can't you know I only
see Twitter clips now but it's pretty
obvious it's like these this this
machine would love for This Disaster to
have been worse to to get to santis do
you think that's too much to say that or
do you agree with that no it's oh oh my
God no it's definitely not too much the
media is capable of anything the darkest
things you can possibly imagine they're
capable of it they're very agenda driven
so yes and what they're doing to sand us
now in Lee County it was like why didn't
you cover Lee County he's like well the
course of the hurricane changed and when
it changed we gave an evacuation order
and they're like oh but it takes 20
hours for the people on the outskirts to
evacuate well take it up with hurricane
Ian right be any and to desantis's
credit he said to the media where were
you you weren't in Lee right you guys
were all in Tampa you were in Tampa so
like save it but if they smell smell
blood in the water you know they're
gonna they love it when it's a
Republican and there was just a report I
think I think it was Maggie Haberman in
the New York Times he was saying
something like a lot of the times you
have to wait you have to wait to see the
damage to know what kind of a job the
leader has done so it's basically like
so far he's done a good job but just
let's hold our fire because I'm sure
there'll be disasters popping up that we
can blame on him later
it really it's it's so gross it really
is just so absolutely gross what do you
want to happen with the Trump DeSantis
thing
well I just think anybody else could win
if Trump runs so and I don't I just
really you think if they got on a stage
you you don't think that the scientist
is is Crafty enough or the record stands
enough to really interesting I don't
even think that a little
um I think Trump sucks up all the energy
in every room no matter what and even
someone is skilled as a politician and
smart policy wise as DeSantis can't
overcome that he can't
it the only way DeSantis is going to
become the Republican nominee is if
Trump chooses not to run and endorses
him or dies
like I just don't see a world in which
Trump says I want it let's say he says I
want it and DeSantis beats him fair and
square in the primary you really think
the hardcore Maga is going to abandon
Trump for DeSantis they're not I talk to
them all the time I I take calls from
them on my radio show and they won't
they they like DeSantis but they don't
think it's his turn they think Trump was
screwed out of his last election that he
was screwed out of his first term by all
the craziness of the Russia gate and so
on and they think he's he is entitled he
deserves another shot at it and so
unless Trump
gracefully and graciously says Get
Behind DeSantis
I I wouldn't put any chips on DeSantis
at all
that's really interesting I mean look I
I've said many times I'd love love for
them to work it out on the deal have a
dinner figure out what has to be figured
out and go forward a lot of people and
I'm sort of moving on this a little bit
say that they should just get on the
debate stage and do it and and whoever
you know comes out will be sharper for
it
um but I agree there is a certain
portion of like the base base that would
rather burn everything down if if it
doesn't get to Trump but it's huge
portion Dave it's a huge portion like
the hardcore Trump Faithful Is
unshakable and there I've I again I hear
from them all the time they're they like
him they like DeSantis but they would
never cross Trump for him and they think
that DeSantis owes his political career
to Trump like if forced to choose they
will choose Trump so DeSantis can't take
him down it's like the line in war games
the only winning move is not to play
DeSantis has got to either be crowned by
Trump
um or you shouldn't run he's he's Trump
it'll it would be
I I don't know I don't he it wouldn't I
was gonna say it's not gonna be a
Kamikaze Mission because he wouldn't
take down Trump right only Trump can
take down Trump
um but he won't win over Trump I I'll
stand by that you can play it against me
if I'm wrong but I won't be by the way
I'm not even totally sure I want him to
run I I love Florida so much and I know
how much he loves it and I know how this
state is flourishing that at some level
just at a I suppose is somewhat selfish
level it's like no stay here let's let's
keep running with this thing and see how
great we can make this state and maybe
the Machinery of the federal government
is just so broken that Swamp Thing maybe
is so all-encompassing that there's not
much you could do there anyway it
wouldn't be bad
to vote for gridlock
yeah it wouldn't be bad to just freeze
the executive's powers which have gotten
too big and this this version of of the
presidency of the executive branch was
never envisioned by the founders it's
gotten too big and too out of control
however
if we froze it as it is now if we're
voting for gridlock from you know in
2024 and 2022 and 2024 and Beyond well
then we're going to be stuck with a lot
of bad Biden policies and I I would love
to see some of those reversed for
example due process for young men
accused on college campuses which is
about to switch back to bidens and
Obama's worldview unless this public
comment period which was very anti-
their changes changes things but uh you
know he doesn't want due process for
accused men on campuses he wants trans
girls to be competing against biological
girls and girls Sports there's a lot of
stuff that Biden's done that needs to be
undone and then if we could just like
undo it and put us back to stasis then
I'm all for gridlock you know I I don't
want a big executive I'd much rather see
Governors make policy and you know do
police power things and so on
so since you can say whatever you think
about all sorts of stuff these days and
you mentioned Biden
do you think he's all there what do you
think is really going on here at this
point who do you think is running this
thing it cannot be him right
Joe Biden is not okay
there's no question in my mind all the
signs of dementia are present and
increasing it's getting worse by the day
the being lost all the time that's a
sign the increase in slurrency there's a
hold on to someone's understand that's a
sign of dementia
the inability to remember who's dead and
who's alive even though moments earlier
you saw a tribute to this representative
from Indiana Jackie wolorski and then
you look around the room and say where
is she you just you just saw a tribute
you wrote a letter to her family I
realized he didn't do it he knew she was
dead he'd been told it wasn't just a few
weeks it was two months earlier he
forgot it's a sign of dementia
um all even
the way we mock how he says something
and then the White House comes out a day
later and does the cleanup you know like
no no we're not going to go into Taiwan
if China invades we're not yeah that's
that's not and uh it depends on if it's
a minor incursion and oh no I'm former
regime change in Russia all three you
know right his his minions at the White
House or his controllers run out and say
didn't mean it not a change in policy
that's part of it he's not in control of
what he says of what he blurts out and
he's the one who in that 60 Minutes Dave
said watch me yep the question by Scott
Pelley was are you fit and he said to us
watch me
well we have we are and we're deeply
alarmed we're coming up on November
that's when the annual physical is there
must be a cognitive test the results of
which must be publicly released Trump
did it in 18 and Biden has to do it and
it better be with somebody who we trust
and not some hack
I hate to tell you but I don't think
we're getting the results of that test
unless unless and I think this is
probably what the move will be which is
if they get completely hammered in the
midterms they're going to need the
scapegoat and you just figure out a way
to just dump it all on Biden he has to
step down and I honestly I'm not sure
they'd give it to Kamala they'd figure
out some weird way to get Gavin Newsom
in there or something no way they can't
possibly give it to her honestly like
I'm sorry but this is not a smart person
she's really not she's not like I sorry
um but and she may be more prone to
verbal gaffs than he is without the
dementia right right so he's got an
excuse right um so they can't and they
know they can't
Adam
um no Mark garagos and Adam Carolla were
on my show and Mark was saying he thinks
that they may take Karen bass
um you know running for LA mayor and
pluck her like replace Kamala Harris
with a different person
um who's diverse who would check some
boxes like the only way to get rid of
Kamala Harris is you know stay in the
diverse Lane
um and maybe get rid of her that way I
don't know I thought the whole thing was
going to be Giver the Supreme Court
Judge ship and turf her out that way and
then open up that second in command spot
now I don't know I know Gavin Newsom has
great hair yeah I see it too soulless he
has no soul there's a soul behind the
hair as soon as America gets a closer
look at him and his policies they're
going to run he's a squad member that's
how far left he is he can't do it
America is still a center-right country
we are there's no way Gavin Newsom
becomes president not not now not unless
he really changes all of his policies
isn't it incredible though that the how
the media runs cover for them no matter
what so like you know you mentioned a
couple of Biden's big gaffs the the
Taiwan one for example but it's like do
you remember what was it six weeks ago
or so that Biden said he had cancer and
then basically within two minutes
everybody was like no no it's not that
he has cancer it's that he has dementia
so he just misremembered the cat and
it's like how do you guys they're doing
the magic trick right in front of us and
everybody falls for it every time yeah
yeah well I mean there's one a day right
it's like I'm a Puerto Rican I was
basically raised Puerto Rican with
Puerto Rican Oh you mean in the yurt
state which had
0.8 Puerto Rican population you had 3
000 Puerto Ricans out of 550 000
delawareans and you were raised by
Puerto Ricans no you weren't right these
are like the media doesn't care they
they actually wind up if you try to fact
check Biden on any of these absurd
claims they weren't out there and then
they fact checked you like Kamala Harris
the thing that you kicked it off with
and her racist comments about how you
you have to be a a group in need of
equity in order to get Hurricane Relief
um I think it was the Washington Post
did a fact check on some senator who
said she's making race the basis for
Relief and they were like fact check
lacks context once you fact check her
claim because what she said Is A Lie the
White House had to disavow it FEMA said
it's not true where's that back check ah
we covered it on my show and we'll
continue to cover it Megan as I often
tell you you're on my short list of sane
people which keeps getting shorter I
don't know if that's good for you or bad
for you or what but uh it's good to see
you my friend it's an honor great to see
you again
and next time over tequila in the Free
State of Florida
oh sounds amazing done considered done
see you there all right if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about the media instead of
non-stop yelling check out our media
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out the full episode playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell